[music playing]
SAL: 90 kilos of cocaine were
found in the trunk of a vehicle
at a Border Patrol checkpoint.
The markings of the cocaine
packages were the scorpion.
This was the label for
Amado and the Juarez Cartel.
[music playing]
If this guy was connected
to the Juarez Cartel,
I knew this was
the break I needed.
ACTOR AS SAL: Come with me.
SAL: I said, "My name is Sal."
I said, "What's your name?"
He says, "I'm Rudy."
I told him, I said, "Listen,
you're in a lot of trouble.
The only way you're
going to get out of this
is by telling me what you
know about this organization."
He tells me, "I can't
cooperate with you.
They're going to kill me."
And I said, "They're
going to kill you anyways
if I let you go,
because right here you
lost a lot of their drugs."
He says, "If I give you
information about the Cartel,
can you go on and protect me?
So I said, "Listen,
you want my help?
You need to go on and
give me information
that's going to be worthwhile."
He knew that he was
in a no-win situation.
He says, "The Cartel
is sending somebody
from Juarez to make
sure that everything
runs smooth on this load.
They call him El Guapo.
He's one of the shot
callers for the Cartel."
Trying to penetrate any
criminal organization,
the only way to do it is to
actually do undercover work.
So I am thinking, wow, this is
going to be a great opportunity
to get somebody
higher in the Cartel
by role playing as
an Undercover Agent.
I asked him, I said, "How
can I be a part of this?"
He goes, "We need a driver."
Now I was going to be a
driver for the Cartel.
ACTOR AS SAL: Let's move out.
SAL: But.
I had no idea what I
had just signed up for.
[music playing]
SAL: The next day, I drive to
a warehouse in the outskirts
of El Paso as an
Undercover Agent
with the 90 kilos
of cocaine that
were seized the day before.
El Guapo was going
to inspect it.
I had backup, numerous DEA
Agents all over the place.
At the same time, I was
very nervous and unsure
of what was going to happen.
[music playing]
[gun clicking]
We're waiting on
El Guapo to show up.
I can see that Rudy
is definitely nervous.
[door closes]
The door opens and
here comes El Guapo.
I could just feel the
energy with this guy
and it was not a good thing.
He's a Cartel manager
in a position of power.
I was intimidated, the
same time, I had to go on
and do what I was
supposed to do.
ACTOR AS SAL: I'm Sal.
I'll be driving.
SAL: He just looked at me and
he goes, "How do you know Rudy?"
And I said, "Well, me
and Rudy go back a ways."
He had no idea Rudy
had betrayed him.
He's staring me up and down.
He notices the gun
under my belt. He says,
"That's a pretty good
sized gun you got there."
I said, "Yeah."
And he goes, "Let me see it."
[suspenseful music]
And he starts looking
at it, inspecting it.
I was getting nervous.
[gun clicking]
But all of a sudden, he
puts the gun to my head
and he asked me--
MAN: "So tell me again
how you know Rudy?"
SAL: I thought to
myself, holy, he's
going to blow my brains out.
So I just said--
ACTOR AS SAL: "Hey, listen.
Stop busting my balls."
SAL: He cracked a smile,
and lowered the gun,
and handed it back to me.
Inside I was furious.
I wanted to get that
gun and shove it up his.
MAN: Unload the coke.
SAL: But I had to keep
my cool and continue
with what we were going to do.
We unload the cocaine
and the whole time,
El Guapo was just standing
there watching us.
My heart was racing
and I'm thinking,
OK, maybe I hit the
mother load here.
This was enough to arrest him.
Eventually, he ended up saying,
"Go on and get out of here."
MAN: This thing will
be moving tomorrow.
SAL: This is the
opportunity that I wanted.
OK, I just pull out my gun.
[gun clicking]
ACTOR AS SAL: DEA!
SAL: "Put your hands up
where I can see them."
[guns clicking]
[speaking spanish]
SAL: He was furious.
He wanted to kick
my ass right there
but I knew I had the
upper hand this time.
[music playing]